Merci beaucoup, Chris. C'est vraiment un honneur
de pouvoir venir sur cette scène une deuxième fois. Je suis très reconnaissant.
J'ai été très impressionné par cette conférence, et je tiens à vous remercier tous pour vos nombreux
et sympathiques commentaires sur ce que j'ai dit l'autre soir.
Et je dis çà sincèrement, en autres parce que --Faux sanglot-- j'en ai besoin ! --Rires--
Mettez-vous à ma place!
J'ai volé avec Air Force 2 pendant huit ans.
Et maintenant, je dois enlever mes chaussures pour monter à bord d'un avion !
--Rires Applaudissements--
Je vais vous raconter une petite histoire pour vous montrer ce que çà a été pour moi.
C'est une histoire vraie, dans tous ses détails.
Après que Tipper et moi avons quitté la --Faux sanglot-- Maison Blanche --Rires--
nous étions en route pour une petite ferme que nous avons
à 80 km à l'est de Nashville --
conduisant nous-mêmes.
Je sais que ça doit vous paraître sans importance mais --Rires--
en jetant un oeil sur le rétroviseur, j'ai réalisé tout à coup.
Il n'y avait pas d'escorte derrière.
Vous avez déjà entendu parlé de douleur du membre fantôme? --Rires--
C'était une Ford Taurus de location. C'était l'heure de dîner
et on s'est mis à chercher un endroit pour manger.
On était sur la I-40. Nous avons pris la sortie 238, Lebanon dans le Tennessee.
Après être sortis, on a commencé à chercher un -- on a trouvé un Shoney's.
Une chaîne de restauration familiale à bas prix, pour ceux d'entre vous qui l'ignorent.
On est entrés et la serveuse est arrivée.
Elle était très impressionnée de voir... Tipper. --Rires--
Elle a pris nos commandes et s'est dirigée vers la table à côté de la nôtre.
Elle leur parlait tout bas et j'ai vraiment dû tendre l'oreille pour entendre ce qu'elle disait.
Elle a dit :"Oui, c'est l'ancien vice-président Al Gore et sa femme Tipper;"
Et l'homme a répondu, " Il est tombé bien bas, hein ?" --Rires--
Il y a eu plusieurs moments de prise de conscience comme celui-là.
Le jour suivant, je continue mon histoire authentique.
J'ai pris un jet vers l'Afrique pour faire un discours au Nigéria,
à Lagos, sur le thème de l'énergie.
Et j'ai commencé mon discours en racontant l'histoire qui m'était arrivée
la veille à Nashville.
Je l'ai racontée comme je viens de le faire avec vous.
Tipper et moi conduisant nous-mêmes, le restaurant familial pas cher Shoney's,
ce que l'homme a dit -- Et ils ont ri.
J'ai fait mon discours et je suis retourné à l'aéroport pour rentrer chez moi.
Je me suis endormi pendant le vol, jusqu'au milieu de la nuit,
où nous nous sommes posés aux Açores pour faire le plein.
Je me suis levé, ils ont ouvert la porte et je suis sorti pour prendre l'air.
Et j'ai vu un homme courir à travers la piste.
Il agitait un papier et criait :
"Appelez Washington, Appelez Washington!"
Alors je me suis dit, en pleine nuit, au milieu de l'Atlantique,
je me demande bien quel genre de problème il pourrait y avoir à Washington?
Et je me suis rappelé que ça pourrait être plein de choses, en fait.
--Rires--
Mais en fait, ce qui se passait c'est que mes collaborateurs étaient paniqués parce qu'
une agence de presse au Nigéria avait déjà écrit un article sur mon discours.
Et il avait déjà été publié dans tous les Etats Unis d'Amérique.
même à Monterey, j'ai vérifié. Et l'article disait :
"L'ancien vice-président Al Gore a annoncé hier au Nigéria,
"Ma femme Tipper et moi avons ouvert un restaurant familial à bas prix, le Shoney's,
et nous nous en occupons nous-mêmes." --Rires--
Avant même d'avoir posé le pied aux USA,
David Letterman et Jay Leno s'étaient déjà jetés sur l'histoire
-- l'un d'eux me montrait sur une photo avec une toque de chef,
et avec Tipper disant "Un autre hamburger avec des frites, s'il vous plaît!"
Trois jours plus tard, j'ai reçu une belle lettre manuscrite de mon ami, partenaire
et collègue Bill Clinton me disant : "Félicitations pour ton nouveau restaurant, Al !"
--Rires--
On aime bien se féliciter quand l'un d'entre nous réussit quelque chose.
J'allais parler d'écologie de l'information.
Mais comme je compte faire de mes visites chez TED une habitude régulière,
je me disais que je pourrais peut-être en parler une autre fois --Applaudissements--
Chris Anderson: Marché conclu!
Al Gore: Je voudrais approfondir un aspect sur lequel beaucoup d'entre vous ont demandé plus d'information.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire contre le réchauffement climatique? J'aimerais commencer avec --
Je vais vous montrer de nouvelles diapositives et je vais juste en détailler quatre ou cinq.
Je mets à jour ma présentation à chaque fois que je la donne.
J'ai ajouté de nouvelles diapositives parce que j'apprends de nouvelles choses à chaque présentation.
C'est comme la marée : à chaque fois que la mer se retire,
vous trouvez de nouveaux coquillages.
On vient de recevoir il y a deux jours les résultats des températures de janvier.
Cela porte sur les USA. La moyenne historique
de Janvier est de 31 °F (0 °C). Celle du mois dernier est de 39.5 °F (4 °C).
Comme je sais que vous vouliez plus de mauvaises nouvelles pour l'environnement
-- je plaisante -- mais voici les diapositives récapitulatives,
et après je passerai à ce que vous pouvez faire à votre échelle.
Mais je voulais détailler quelques diapos avant.
Tout d'abord, ceci montre la projection de la contribution des USA au réchauffement climatique
si l'on continue sur la même voie. L'efficacité énergétique au niveau de l'utilisateur final
voilà un objectif à portée de main. Efficacité et économie:
Il ne s'agit pas d'un coût mais d'un profit. Le signe est faux.
Ce n'est pas un moins, c'est un plus. Ce sont des investissements qui se paient tous seuls.
Et ils sont aussi très efficaces pour infléchir la courbe.
J'ai parlé des voitures et des camions dans la présentation,
mais il faut les ramener à une vision d'ensemble.
Ce sont des sujets de préoccupation visibles et évidents, ce qui est bien,
mais les logements sont une source de pollution à effet de serre plus importante
que les voitures et les camions.
Les voitures et les camions jouent un rôle important et nos normes d'émission sont les moins exigeants du monde,
et il faut s'en occuper. Mais ce n'est qu'un morceau du puzzle.
L'efficacité énergétique des autres types de transports pèse aussi lourd que celle des voitures et camions.
Les énergies renouvelables à leur niveau technologique actuel
peuvent produire cette baisse, et, avec Vinod, John Doerr et d'autres,
dont beaucoup sont là -- et de nombreuses personnes très impliquées
-- ce secteur va croître beaucoup plus vite que ne le laisse voir la projection actuelle.
Les pièges à carbone -- c'est ce que CCS veut dire
-- sont en passe de devenir l'arme suprême
qui nous permettra de continuer à utiliser des combustibles fossiles sans dommage pour la planète.
Nous n'en sommes cependant pas encore là.
OK. Alors, que pouvez-vous faire ? Vous pouvez réduire vos émissions de CO2 dans votre habitation.
La pluspart de ces dépenses vous feront économiser de l'argent.
Isolation, meilleure conception, achetez de l'electricité verte quand vous le pouvez.
Je parlais des voitures plus tôt. Achetez un modèle à propulsion hybride.
Ayez recours à d'autres moyens de transport quand ils sont plus économes. C'est important.
Soyez un consommateur écologique. Pour chaque chose que vous achetez, vous pouvez choisir
entre des objets à fort impact sur l'environnement et d'autres
dont l'effet est beaucoup plus limité.
Pensez à çà : Prenez la décision de mener une vie à "empreinte carbone nulle"
Ceux d'entre vous qui s'y connaissent en création de marques (branding),
j'aimerais beaucoup avoir votre aide
pour dire cela d'une manière qui soit la plus parlante possible.
C'est plus facile que vous ne pensez. Vraiment.
Beaucoup d'entre nous ici ont déjà pris cette décision et c'est vraiment assez facile.
Réduisez vos émissions de CO2 grâce à toute la palette de choix qui s'offre à vous
et pour ce que vous n'avez pas pu supprimer, achetez des droits d'émission.
Pour mieux comprendre, allez sur climatecrisis.net
Il y a un calculateur d'émissions de CO2. De nombreux participants se sont rassemblés,
sous mon implication active et les programmateurs les mieux formés au monde
sur la science complexe du calcul des émissions de carbone ont permis de mettre au point
un calculateur d'émission de carbone utilisable par n'importe qui.
Vous pouvez calculer de manière très précise le niveau de vos émissions de CO2,
après quoi vous sont proposées des solutions pour réduire vos émissions.
Et à la sortie du film en mai, le programme passera en version 2.0
et proposera des liens directs pour acheter des droits d'émission.
Ensuite, réfléchissez à faire de votre emploi une activité à empreinte carbone nulle. Là aussi, certains d'entre nous ont déjà franchi le pas
et ce n'est pas aussi dur qu'on ne pense. Intégrez des solutions vertes dans chacune de vos innovations,
que vous veniez du monde de la technologie, du spectacle,
du design ou de celui de l'architecture.
Investissez dans le développement durable. Majora en a parlé.
Si vous confiez de l'argent à des responsables d'entreprises
dont la rémunération dépend de la performance annuelle,
ne venez pas vous plaindre du fait que l'entreprise soit gérée par trimestre.
Au final, les gens font ce pour quoi vous les payez. Et s'ils estiment
que la part de leur rémunération liée à votre investissement,
sera calculée sur la base de profits à court terme, vous n'obtiendrez que des décisions à court terme.
Il y aurait beaucoup plus à dire à ce sujet.
Devenez un catalyseur de changement. Expliquez aux autres, informez-vous, parlez-en autour de vous.
Quand le film sort -- le film est une version filmée de la présentation
que j'ai faite il y a deux jours, à part qu'elle est beaucoup plus attrayante. Il sort en mai.
Beaucoup d'entre vous peuvent faire en sorte que beaucoup de monde le voient.
Voyez si vous avez quelqu'un à envoyer à Nashville. Choisissez bien.
Et je me chargerai personnellement de former ces personnes pour qu'à leur tour, elles fassent cette présentation
remaniée pour qu'elle puisse être faite par n'importe qui.
et -- ce n'est pas tant les diapos que ce qu'elle veulent dire et comment elles sont liées les unes aux autres.
Et je vais donc donner un cours cet été
à un groupe de personnes choisies pour apprendre et après faire la présentation à leur tour,
en masse, auprès de communautés à travers tout le pays.
Et nous mettrons la présentation à jour chaque semaine
pour qu'elle soit toujours au fait des évènements.
En collaboration avec Larry Lessig, elle sera diffusée
avec des outils et des droits de reproduction limités
pour que les jeunes puissent puiser dedans et la refaire à leur façon.
--Applaudissements--
D'où vient cette idée qu'il faut rester à l'écart de la politique ?
Je ne veux pas dire que j'essaie de vous convertir, si vous êtes un Républicain,
en Démocrate. Nous avons aussi besoin des Républicains. Par le passé, ce problème dépassait les clivages politiques
et je sais que c'est le cas dans ce groupe. Devenez actifs sur le plan politique.
Faites marcher notre démocratie comme elle devrait marcher.
Apportez votre soutien à l'idée d'une limitation des émissions de CO2 et des gaz à effet de serre
ainsi qu'à leur commerce. Voici pourquoi : tant que les USA seront en dehors du système mondial,
il ne sera pas global.
Une fois que le système est global, avec la participation des USA,
alors tout membre d'un conseil d'administration
-- combien de personnes ici font partie d'un conseil d'administration ?
Une fois que le système est global, vous aurez une responsabilité légale d'inciter votre PDG
à maximiser le revenu lié aux réductions d'émissions de CO2 et au commerce de celles
qui peuvent être évitées. C'est le marché tout entier qui oeuvrera alors à résoudre ce problème.
Contribuez à la campagne de persuasion de masse qui débutera au printemps.
Nous devez changer l'état d'esprit du peuple Américain. Parce que à l'heure actuelle,
les hommes politiques n'ont pas la permission de faire ce qui doit être fait.
Dans notre pays, la raison et la logique ne permettent plus
d'arbitrer entre la richesse et le pouvoir comme c'était le cas par le passé.
Il n'y a plus que la répétition de spots publicitaires de 30 ou 28 secondes.
Nous devons acheter beaucoup de ces spots.
Trouvons une nouvelle marque pour le réchauffement climatique comme bon nombre d'entre vous l'ont suggéré.
Je préfère crise climatique à effondrement climatique
mais je le répète, ceux d'entre vous qui s'y connaissent en branding, j'ai besoin de votre aide.
Un scientifique m'a dit un jour que le problème que nous avons devant nous
revient à savoir si une espèce dotée de pouce opposable
et d'une conscience est une combinaison viable.
C'est vraiment çà. Je l'ai dit hier soir et je le répète : ceci n'est pas une question de politique.
Et aux Républicains qui sont ici je dis : ce n'est pas une question de parti.
Vous avez plus d'influence que certains d'entre nous Démocrates n'en ont.
C'est une opportunité. Pas seulement çà, mais avec les idées présentées ici,
d'être plus cohérent entre nous.
Nous sommes tous dans le même bateau.
Merci beaucoup. Merci.
--Applaudissements--